worked on vaccine trials for Ebola next
dr. Robert Redfield director of the u.s.
Center for Disease Control and
Prevention CDC for more than 30 years
he's been involved with clinical
research related to chronic human viral
infections and infectious diseases
especially HIV it was founding director
of the department of retroviral research
within the US military's HIV research
program and retired after 20 years of
service with the US Army Medical Corps
third admiral brent jawad Admiral juruá
is the assistant secretary for health at
the US Department of Health and Human
Services he oversees the development of
the department's public health policy
recommendations specific to Cova 19
response
Admiral juruá has taken on testing and
focused on increasing the number of
tests we can do with existing technology
his federal service includes directing
the defense sciences office of the
Defense Advanced Research Projects
Agency and a variety of other important
responsibilities finally we will hear
from dr. Stephen Hahn dr. Hahn's
commissioner of the US Food and Drug
Administration the FDA before joining
FDA he held leadership positions as
chief medical Executive at the
University of Texas MD Anderson Cancer
Center in his chair of the Department of
radiation oncology at the University of
Pennsylvania early in his career he was
senior investigator at the National
Cancer Institute at the National
Institutes of Health
he's been commander of the US Public
Health Service commissioned Corps in
2005 we welcome our witnesses
dr. Falchi welcome let's begin with you
thank you very much mr. chairman ranking
member Murray members of the committee
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to discuss briefly with you today the
role of the National Institutes of
Health and research addressing kovat 19
and as you indicated
the Chairman I will during the question
period and alluding to in the
presentation addressed some of the
issues regarding schools the NIAID NIH
strategic plan for covered research
involves four major components the first
is to improve the fundamental knowledge
of understanding of the biology of the
virus and the immune response to the
virus in order to better inform us in
the development of Diagnostics
therapeutics and vaccines some of the
work that has come out of that program
right now informs very greatly
how we will address vaccine development
particularly understanding the
conformation of the components of the
virus that induce an appropriate immune
response in addition we will develop in
are developing animal models apropos of
what you mentioned about children in
school we have a program called heroes
which is human epidemiology and response
to saws coronavirus which is determining
the incidents and transmissibility among
children a very important issue when you
talk about opening schools and the
impact that might have in addition the
development of Diagnostics point-of-care
sensitive and specific diagnostics under
the rad x program including the rat x up
for underserved populations third to
characterize and test therapeutics you
mentioned the importance of this as we
open up schools there are a number of
programs very active that have already
shown efficacy or not in some drugs as
well as a number of clinical trials that
are ongoing one in particular was the
first randomized placebo-controlled
trial showing that the drug renessa BIA
diminishes by about 32 percent the time
it takes to get to recovery and people
with advanced disease pulmonary
involvement in addition we have another
study combining this with an
anti-inflammatory agent next we have
vaccines as several have mentioned it's
extremely important to have safe and
effective vaccines available for
everyone in this country as well as
globally in that regard we put together
myself and some of my
colleagues and published in science
magazine a few weeks ago what we call a
strategic approach to coronavirus 19
vaccine research and development it's
not a comprehensive plan about every
aspect a vaccine but it is a strong plan
regarding the research and development
pathway and what we have done in this is
that we have what's called a harmonized
effect because we know there are many
vaccines that are in trial now at
various stages and what we did and the
federal government thanks the generosity
of the Congress has put a considerable
amount of money in order to harmonize
the trials of multiple candidates from
different companies so that we have
common endpoints common datum and safety
monitoring board and common
immunological parameters that are being
funded and are being pursued in addition
there are a number of different
platforms that are being pursued so that
we don't have all our eggs in one basket
as you know one of those is right now
getting ready as we approach next month
of going into Phase three trials and
others will be staggered along the way
in the middle of the summer end of the
summer early on there was no guarantee
and anyone who's been involved in
vaccinology will tell you that we will
have a safe and effective vaccine but we
are cautiously optimistic looking at
animal data and the early preliminary
data that we will at least know the
extent of efficacy some time in the
winter and early part of next year again
working with the companies and the
investment made by this Congress
hopefully there will be doses available
by the beginning of next year these are
the things that we feel aspirationally
hopeful about and we would continue to
pursue this I'll stop there mr. chairman
and be happy to answer questions later
thank you thank you dr. Falchi dr.
Redfield welcome good morning chairman
Alexander ranking member Murray and
distinguished members of the committee I
want to thank you for the opportunity to
testify before you today with my HHS
colleagues the coven 19 pandemic is the
moe
significant global public health
challenge that we have faced as a nation
in more than a century in the United
States daily cases are increasing after
an extended decline we're seeing
significant increases in the southeast
and southwest regions of this nation the
number of jurisdictions in upward
trajectory has continued to increase now
29 of 55 jurisdictions fall into this
category the evidence tells us that
these cases are driven by many factors
to include increased testing community
transmission and outbreaks in the
settings such as nursing homes and
occupational settings hospitalizations
now are going up in 12 states and as of
this weekend daily death now has
increased in the state of Arizona
CDC is closely monitoring these increase
and have 48 teams with more than 140
staff currently deployed in 20 states
and two territories CDC is providing
technical expertise to the health
department's and epidemiology contact
tracing infection prevention and control
and communication beyond providing this
critical boots on the ground CDC is
working with your States and community
in other ways CDC is speaking with the
state's tribal local and territorial
health department's on a daily basis to
develop strategies to stop kovat while
reopening businesses and schools the
initial guidance for Institutes of
higher learning which shared in March
and the K through 12 setting was shared
in February
both these guidances have been updated
since and over the past several months
as more information becomes available
we'll continue to disseminate that more
broadly CDC release consolidated
recommendations for COBIT testing
including interim testing guidelines for
nursing homes as well as testing options
for high-density critical infrastructure
workplaces after a Kovach case is
identified testing guidance for higher
education in K through 12 the k higher
education should be posted today in K
through 12 later this week these
recommendations are consistent with
previously published testing
guidelines and are meant to supplement
not replace the guidance of local
jurisdictions CC continues to advance
science around the cove in nineteen
impact in certain populations and those
who are at heightened risk for severe
outcomes
our most recent analysis of the United
States case data fanned the pandemic
hospitalizations were six times higher
and death twelve times higher among
those with reportedly underlying
conditions compared to those who did not
have these conditions we've expanded the
list of underlying conditions where the
evidence is clear that they put people
at higher risk of severe illness these
conditions include chronic kidney
disease COPD having a weakened immune
system from an solid organ transplant
obesity serious heart disease sickle
cell disease and type 2 diabetes our
analysis also provides further evidence
evidence that racial and ethnic
populations are disproportionately
affected by this epidemic
while date is the backbone of this
response containing the outbreak depends
on four core interventions readily
available testing comprehensive contact
tracing timely isolation of known cases
and quarantined to break the
transmission we are not defenseless
against this disease we have powerful
tools at our disposal social distancing
wear face cover in public and be
disciplined about the frequent
hand-washing it is critical that we all
take the personal responsibility to slow
the transmission of COBIT 19 and embrace
the universal use of face coverings
specifically I'm addressing the younger
members of our society the Millennials
and new generation Z's I ask those that
are listening to spread the word before
I close I'd like to speak briefly about
how CDC is assisting the frontlines of
our health department's to fight Kovan
with your support
CDC has awarded 12 billion dollars to 64
jurisdictions data monetization is
underway public health laboratories are
building resilience number of contact
tracers have grown 345 percent the
disease impacts us all and it's going to
take all of us working together to stop
together I believe we can achieve the
possible thank you and I look forward to
your questions
thank you dr. Redfield Admiral Jawad
welcome chairman Alexander ranking
member Murray and distinguished members
of the committee it's good to see all of
you again first I want to clarify my
current role on March 12th secretary
azar requested that I lead the
coordination of kovat 19 testing efforts
within the department to be clear
although I am assuming some of my
traditional duties as the assistant
secretary I am maintaining my role
coordinating testing including now the
NIH red X Diagnostics program along with
dr. Collins to assure that innovations
are immediately translated into practice
in order to get back safely to work in
school the overarching most critical an
essential action we must first
accomplish is to control the virus
meaning rapidly extinguishing any
outbreaks and minimizing community
transmission all of us are concerned
about recent data from several states
indicating rising infections and now an
uptick in hospitalizations and deaths
even as other states and the majority of
counties are maintaining a low infection
burden knowing what we know now about
asymptomatic transmission and the fact
that we are in a much better position
today in terms of our mitigation
strategies PPE and testing we can
reverse these concerning trends if we
work together
first we must take personal
responsibility and be disciplined about
our own behavior maintain physical
distancing wear a face covering whenever
you can't physically distance wash your
hands stay at home if you feel sick if
you have been in close contact with
someone infected or in a gathering
without appropriate precautions get
tested shield the elderly and the
vulnerable of any age and follow the
guidelines for opening up America again
the criteria are very specific and are
as relevant today as when we release
in addition this week we are initiating
surge testing in multiple communities of
highest concern in coordination with
state and local officials now schools
and businesses as dr. Redfield stated
the CDC will release recommendations on
K through 12 institutions of higher
education and general business reopening
these will include considerations for
integrating testing especially
surveillance testing into a
comprehensive strategy as you asked me
mr. chairman if you are a superintendent
of a school system or a president of a
university number one apply the CDC
guidelines in consultation with your
state and local public health officials
so that testing is a part of your
comprehensive plan which should also
include prevention and clear mechanisms
to isolate positive students number to
assure your testing needs are
incorporated into your state testing
plans as we outlined in the national
testing strategy each state has
developed and will continue to build
upon a customized to state testing plan
developed in full coordination with the
federal government the next iteration
covering July to December is due on July
10th these state plans drive the
allocation of certain scarce resources
for example in May and June
the federal government has distributed
nearly twenty-six million collection
swabs and over 19 million tubes of
transport media HHS also prioritizes
allocation of certain key laboratory
tests like point-of-care tests according
to state specific needs
there are also strategies particularly
relevant to surveillance testing
especially in universities and
businesses for example pooling of
samples meaning combining two or more
samples and possibly up to ten into a
single test makes sense where the
prevalence of infection is low and such
pooled surveillance testing can be
conducted in a university research lab
outside of a CLIA environment but if a
pooled sample is positive for kovat
every individual in that pool would need
to be tested through
system I would like to close by
recognizing my fellow officers in the
United States Public Health Service
commissioned Corps the uniformed service
that I lead 4536 officers have deployed
to support the pandemic response
exemplifying the care and compassion
that all of us feel for those who have
suffered during this pandemic I thank
each and every one of these officers and
their families and on their behalf
sincerely thank all of you in Congress
for supporting our training needs in
establishment of a Ready Reserve Corps
to supplement our ranks during
inevitable future national emergencies
thank you for the opportunity to provide
these remarks thank you Thank You
Admiral juruá welcome dr. Hahn thank you
chairman Alexander a ranking member Mary
and members of the help committee I
appreciate very much the support that
you all have provided for our efforts
during this time of coab in nineteen FDA
has a vital role in the federal
government's response to the pandemic
one of our core missions is to advance
the public health by helping to speed
medical products that are safe and
effective we have provided appropriate
regulatory flexibilities to assure that
the American public has access to
critical metal prop medical products and
safe food in confidence that our
decisions are based on medicine and
science since the public health
emergency was declared FDA has issued
more than 100 emergency use
authorization for diagnostic tests
personal protective equipment
ventilators other devices and drug
products and we have issued more than 50
guidance documents to ensure the
continuity of health care in the food
supply I am pleased to announce that
today FDA is taking action to aid the
time timely development of a safe and
effective vaccine to prevent Cova 19 by
providing guidance for developers with
recommendations on the data needed to
facilitate manufacturing clinical
development and approval we recognize
the urgent need to develop a safe and
effective vaccine to prevent koban 19
and we want to work
with industry researchers and other
partners to accelerate these efforts
while the FDA is committed to help
expedite this work we will not cut
corners in our decision-making and we
are making clear in our guidance what
are the data that we need that should be
submitted to meet our regulatory
standards of approval
this is particularly as important as we
know that some people are skeptical of
vaccine development efforts the FDA
strongly encourages the inclusion of
diverse populations in all phases of
clinical development including
populations most affected by Koba 19 and
specifically racial and ethnic
minorities as well as adequate
representation in late phase trials of
elderly individuals and those with
medical comorbidities we also have
information in this guidance about
including women who are pregnant as well
as for pediatric assessments of safety
and effectiveness the American people
should know that we have not lost sight
of our responsibility to maintain our
regulatory independence and ensure that
our decisions related to all medical
products including Kotov at nineteen
vaccines are based on sound science and
the available data this is a commitment
the American public can have confidence
in and that I will continue to uphold
personally while vaccine research is
ongoing rapid testing and therapeutic
development can aid in the safe return
to school college and the workplace FDA
is constantly evaluating new data we
receive on testing so that we can
promote the development of new and
better tests and remove tests that are
not reliable from the market and we have
put into a place an initiative to
accelerate the development of treatments
called the corona virus treatment
acceleration program or SeaTac we've
seen some of the consequences of that
program such as the authorization of REM
des Vere and the recent information
regarding other therapeutics that might
be a benefit to patients with koban
19-hour working day and night to provide
guidance to and review proposals from
companies scientists and researchers who
are developing therapies for koba 19 we
are now preparing for the next phase of
addressing
evolving crisis it is mission-critical
that the agency constantly evaluate
whether our processes are maximal to
promote and protect the public health
and therefore we are beginning a
comprehensive real-time review and
assessment of our actions today to
address the Cova 19 panic pandemic and
I'm glad to answer questions about that
review I want to thank the more than
17,000 FDA employees who've been working
night and day to help expedite medical
products but also to provide the
necessary oversight with the appropriate
science and data we know that the virus
remains with us FDA is committed to
doing the critical work that will get
the country to the point at which
Americans judge it safe to return to
work and school as quickly as possible I
am incredibly proud of the dedicated
women and men of the FDA whose
commitment to defeating this pandemic
has been unwavering I can assure you the
FDA will continue to provide leadership
expertise guidance and information as we
continue to address this unprecedented
challenge and fulfill our mission to
protect and promote public health thank
you and appreciate and look forward to
your questions thank you dr. Hahn and
thanks to each of our witnesses will now
begin around a five-minute questions all
the Senators are participating today
almost all and so I would ask the
senders and a witnesses to try to keep
each segment within five minutes
dr. Falchi assumed I'm superintendent of
one of 14,000 school districts and in
our community we we understand that
their health risks for children going
back to school but we've concluded that
the risk of to their education mental
health and social development is a
greater risk if they don't go back to
school so what would your advice be to a
school superintendent about what he or
she should be thinking about as children
go back to school and a few weeks to
keep them safe thank you for that
question mr. chairman it is an important
question but I think we need to point
out that it really will depend on the
dynamics of the outbreak in the
particular location where the school is
and one of the things we want to
emphasize and have been emphasizing is
to take a look at where you are in the
particular area of the so-called opening
America again are you at the gateway
phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 the CDC has
guidelines about the opening of schools
at various stages of those checkpoints
the basic fundamental goal would be as
you possibly can to get the children
back to school and to use the public
health efforts as a tool to help get
children back to school let me explain
what I mean in other words if we adhere
to guidelines of what we've heard in
many of these presentations you just
heard about the physical distance in the
community the use of masks things like
that that will help to keep the level of
infection in the community down which
will then make it easy to get the
children back to school if you are in an
area where you have a certain amount of
infection dynamics there are things that
can creatively be done about modifying
things like the school schedule
alternate days morning versus evening
allowing under certain circumstances
online virtual lessons those are the
kind of things that we need to consider
but also importantly always make the
goal that it is very important to get
the children back to school for the
unintended negative consequences that
occur when we keep them out of school
thank you doctor dr. Redfield one of the
concerns would be that children who
generally speaking haven't been damaged
nearly as much as adults particularly
elderly adults by this virus might carry
the virus to their teachers
administrators or parents or
grandparents at home it seems to me that
the availability of treatments this fall
medicine for the environments that
reduce the risk
of sickness and death could be very
important in increasing confidence in
going back to school you mentioned some
of those in your testimony are there
others what will the availability of
treatments be this fall and specifically
what about so-called antibody cocktails
of the kind that were developed for
Ebola and approved by the FDA well I
think that'd be a great question also
for dr. pouchy I'm gonna make a small
statement he may want to add to it
clearly we do have reduce very as you
mentioned we have now evidence that
steroids can improve therapy and as you
mentioned we have convalescent plasma
that Stephan and could comment on that's
the using the the antibodies from
individuals that have gotten better from
kovat that are currently under
evaluation and potentially be available
I have just a minute dr. Redfield let me
go to dr. high and let him answer that
question - thank you as I mentioned
Ramdev ear has been authorized based on
its reduction in hospitalization days
the steroids were mentioned convalescent
plasma we have evaluated the safety
through a large expanded access program
at the Mayo Clinic and it's been found
to be safe
over 20,000 patients who administered it
we are waiting for the safety data and
we will be passing those data along to
Barda who's the sponsor of that program
I think that antibody data will help us
in terms of the development of
monoclonal antibodies we have a number
of sponsors who have come in for
monoclonal antibody studies we are
already well into that treatment
monoclonal antibodies are synthetic
antibodies that will provide that the
theory's will provide protection against
the infection of the virus and we're
hopeful that those studies by the late
summer early fall will provide us
information about their effectiveness
and safety so you're optimistic that
there will be more than one treatment
available this fall for teachers
administrators older adults yes there
I'm optimistic thank you very much
senator Murray well thank you
oh very much appreciate your service in
your work dr. Sachi last time you tested
for testified before this committee you
warned us a needless suffering and death
if states begin reopening too early and
just over a month later now we are
seeing a record number of cases we do
not have enough tests and we did not
have enough contact tracers and just
yesterday
CDC's doctor chuckit said we have too
much virus to control in the u.s.
arguing and I quote this is really the
beginning our strategy hasn't worked I
want to ask you what did the federal
government and the more than 30 states
with rising case numbers need to do to
reverse this trend thank you very much
for that question
senator Murray I am also quite concerned
about what we are seeing of all right
now in several of the states as you know
in four of the states in Florida Texas
California and Arizona more than 50% of
the new infections are in those areas
where we're seeing surgeons the things
we need to do I think you alluded to in
your question to me we've got to make
sure that when states start to try and
open again they need to follow the
guidelines that have been very carefully
laid out with regard to checkpoints what
we've seen in several states are
different iterations of that perhaps
maybe in some going too quickly and
skipping over some of the checkpoints
but even in states in which the
leadership in the form of the governors
and the mayors did it right with the
right recommendations what we saw
visually in clips and in photographs of
individuals in the community doing it
all a nun phenomenon which is dangerous
and by all a nun I mean either be locked
down or open up in a way where you see
people at bars not wearing masks not
avoiding crowds not paying attention to
physical distancing I think we need to
emphasize the responsibility that we
have both as individual
and as part of a societal effort to end
the epidemic that we all have to play a
part in that and they think if you look
at the visuals what we saw were a lot of
people who maybe felt that because they
think they are invulnerable
and we know many young people are not
because they're getting serious disease
that therefore they're getting infected
has nothing at all to do with anyone
else when in fact it does because if a
person gets infected they may not be
symptomatic but they could pass it to
someone else who passes it to someone
else who then makes someone's
grandmother grandfather sick uncle or a
leukemic child on chemotherapy gets sick
and died we've got to get that message
out that we are all in this together
and if we are going to contain this
we've got to contain it together health
behavior and wear a mask
we recommend masks for everyone on the
outside anyone who comes into contact in
a crowded area you should avoid crowds
where possible and when you're outside
and not had the capability of
maintaining distance you should wear a
mask at all times
thank you dr. Redfield last week dr.
Julie Kirby Dean who served as a CDC
director under president george w bush
testified to our committee that if she
were in charge one of her top priorities
would be the creation of a National
Vaccine plan that addresses the science
development allocation uptake and
monitoring of a vaccine saying quote we
know this is in our future and we are
not ready for it I couldn't agree more
and that plan has to detail how the
federal government will scale up
manufacturing coordinate the supply
chain so we avoid the missteps we saw
with testing needs to combat
misinformation and vaccine hesitancy and
make sure that vaccine distribution
addresses health disparities and a lot
more dr. Redfield you
a plan like that was needed senator I
think it's very important that we have a
integrated plan for this vaccine when
well I'm gonna ask dr. Hahn if you'd
like to comment I know recently they had
a vaccine plan for at least for the
FDA's perspective CDC is working on the
issues that you said that I think are so
important in building vaccine their
plans CDC would be writing the
comprehensive plan
well we're developing a plan as we as we
speak and again to keep building on the
efforts that we have to rebuild what I
call vaccine confidence in this country
which is really critical and then on top
of that there'll be a very defined plan
for distribution of this vaccine prize a
ssin of this vaccine well it's currently
in development within the group and I'd
you know I'd anticipate that we'll see
that plan in the in the near weeks of
heads head senator weeks not days months
in the weeks ahead it's a collective
effort that we're doing together within
the concept of operation Wharf speed but
CDC's been working on this plan
literally for probably the last 10 to 12
weeks
Oh mr. chairman I would just say we need
to see that plan we need to know what it
is the American public needs to know
what that is communities need to know
what that is
so I hope that we urge that plan to be
public as soon as possible so we all
know what to expect
thank you senator Murray senator burr
Thank You mr. chairman
after working on pandemic policy now for
17 years I'm reminded this morning
Tony felt she's been doing it twice as
long as I have and most of you at the
TAS have been doing that as well
I urge my colleagues pay attention to
what each of these individuals say
because some things are predictable up
here Congress is a full-fledged partner
and funds things when there's an urgent
need a threat that's out there and I
know Tony you've seen over the years
when there's not that threat out there
things get shelved like platforms that
we could have developed and have better
countermeasures today
platforms that then could address
vaccines in a much faster pace than
maybe what we're doing but we spend more
time with the blame game then we do with
focuses on how the future should look
while all of us members of Congress and
people within government wish that we
could get back to normalcy your agencies
and members of Congress are also charged
with making sure that we mapped the
future so the future generations have
better protections in what we have and
that's why I applaud the chairman for
his white paper and I would encourage
every member of that Dyess to be
brutally honest with us about where
changes need to be made and where they
don't need to be made dr. Redfield I
think you would agree with me that
testing and surveillance on this has not
been the best performance by CDC I don't
want to dwell on where we've come up
short share with these members and
myself what can we expect over the next
several months from CDC that will be
different than what the past has looked
like well thank you senator for your
question I think CDC will continue to
work with the state local tribal
territory health departments to build
their capacity I think we all know that
for decades there's been consistent
under investment in public health in
this nation and the core capabilities to
do that job
data data monetization
data analysis laboratory resilience
workforce very appreciative for the
merchants II response find that Congress
provided these are critical
infrastructure issues that the reality
are have been under invested the CDC is
right now probably providing 50 to 70%
of all public health funding to each
state we need to have a much more robust
investment in these core capabilities
what you are going to see because of the
Congress acting CDC has provided now
twelve billion dollars to the local
state territorial tribal health
departments to begin to build that core
capability that we would have liked to
built over the last several decades so
that there's enhanced testing is it's
been mentioned it's complicated here
because this virus is so asymptomatic
for so many so the traditional methods
of diagnosis contact tracing isolation
are going to be inhibited for many
individuals and that's going to require
broader community based surveillance
strategies those plans as was mentioned
by the Admiral are we've received them
for June and July we're working with the
local jurisdictions they're gonna have
him in middle July for the plans for the
rest of the year and we're gonna be
working side by side with them to
continue to augment the public health
capacity responded as kovat virus with
basically enhanced surveillance and
enhanced early diagnosis contact tracing
isolation to begin to bring this
outbreak under control I hope some of
that money will be used to upgrade the
systems at CDC that are antiquated sir I
agree with you there I mean I think as
those of you know when I was given the
opportunity to do this job very early on
within a month I recognized that the
core capabilities of our public health
infrastructure is not there particularly
the one that I know you've been very
supportive of data data monetization
predictive data analysis and and that is
in progress
it can't happen too soon and we're
appreciative of the support that
Congress has given and I do think it's
fundamentally critical to bring our data
system and as you know the data
personnel that we have and we thank you
for your efforts there and as we need to
our
those individuals strategically we will
continue to do that to make sure that
the premier public health agency in this
country has the personnel and data
systems that it does name but I will say
the other big issue we have to correct
is to make sure our public health state
local territorial tribal have that
integrated health system of data dr. Han
I think you have used your authorities
under Papa at FDA in a very effective
way and the FDA's risen to the challenge
during the public health emergency
cutting red tape and maintaining the
agency's gold standard for review of
life-saving medical products you
specifically mentioned innovative trial
clinical trial designs and the use of
real-world data as areas where the FDA
has gained ground during the response -
Kovach how do you plan to ensure that
this progress is maintained long after
the coronavirus response is over thank
you senator burr critical issues that
you bring up in addition some of the
things that we're doing on the review
side to actually expedite review and
work with innovators and developers we
will continue part of our review of our
actions to date so a mid action review
will inform how we move forward no
question the fact that real-world
evidence and modernization of our data
systems are needed particular round
supply chain and demand for medical
products but also on the review cycle
and the innovative clinical design
trials as you mentioned thank you for
that mr. chairman I do hope that you or
another member will allow dr. Falchi at
some point today to make any comments on
the reports that there's a new swine flu
that the Chinese have apparently
identified and how that might affect us
in the future in this country
well dr. Fauci why don't you do that now
if you have anything to say about a
swine flu the Chinese over the last week
or two have identified a virus in the
environment it is not yet shown to be
infect the humans but it is exhibiting
what we call reassortment capabilities
in other words when you get a brand-new
virus that turns out to be a pandemic
virus it's either due to mutations and
or the reassortment or exchanges of
genes and they're seeing virus in swine
in pigs now that have characteristics of
the 2009 h1n1 of the original 1918 which
many of our flu viruses have remnants of
that in it as well as segments from
other hosts like swine when they all mix
up together and they contain some of the
elements that might make them
susceptible to being transmitted to
humans you always have the possibility
that you might have another swine flu
type outbreak as we had in 2009 it's
something that still is in the stage of
examination it's not so called an
immediate threat where you're seeing
infections but it's something we need to
keep our eye out on just the way we did
in 2009 with the emergence of the swine
flu
it's called G for is the name of it
Thank You senator Sanders thank you very
much Alan and let me thank all of our
panelists for being here for the great
work that they are doing on this
pandemic let me ask a question that has
just bothered me lately all of you and I
think most Americans understand how
important social distancing is we're
told over and over again the Chairman
told us at the beginning of this meeting
stay apart at least 6 feet apart if you
can and just the other day however
American Airlines announced that they
were gonna fill up all of their planes
and other airlines have done the same so
you're gonna have people going from New
York to California five six hours
sitting inches apart from each other and
then you got buses all over America
where people are kind of packed in like
sardines my question is why hasn't the
government whether it's the CDC or the
Department of Transportation issued
guidelines prohibiting those violate
Asians of what we all know to be common
sense once the doctor pouchy you want to
start on the winner
you
Thank You senator well I'm I'm not the
CDC but I'd be happy to make a comment
on that and maybe Bob would also I mean
obviously that is something that is of
concern I'm not sure exactly what went
into that decision making
I would hope there would be something to
mitigate against that because I know as
we've said and I continue to repeat it
that avoiding crowds staying distance
and when in a situation like that wear a
mask I think in the confines of an
airplane that becomes even more
problematic but I understand the mask
thing but doesn't it sound a little bit
silly and a little bit in violation of
everything you guys have been talking
about have people sitting next to each
other for five or six hours in an
airplane or crowded into a bus and my
question is why hasn't the president
issues a lot of executive orders why
haven't we stopped that type of activity
and told the airlines and bus companies
that is unhealthy senator I appreciate
your question and I think it's it's a
critical area I can tell you that when
they announced that the other day
obviously there was substantial
disappointment with American Airlines
number of the airlines had decided to
keep the middle seat saying I can't say
this is under critical review right now
by us at CDC we don't think it's the
right message as you pointed out again
we think it's really important in
individuals that are in whether it's a
bus or a train or a plane or a social
distancing the degree that's feasible
and at least have a reliable face
covering so okay well thank you I just
hope very much that the CDC or the
appropriate agency basically tells these
companies that that is unacceptable
behavior they're endangering the lives
of the American people let me go to
another question I just have a few more
questions and not a lot of time so I'd
appreciate brief answers at the
University of Washington the Institute
of Health they're indicated that if
ninety five percent of the American
people were
to wear masks we could save some 30,000
lives a number of countries including
South Korea France Turkey and Austria
have provided low-cost or free masks to
all of their people something that I
believe in
would you support an effort to greatly
increase the production of high-quality
masks in this country and distribute
them free of charge to every household
in America don't you or anybody else
wants to jump in on that yes of course
I think masks is are extremely important
and we keep hammering home and I think
what you just mentioned is is is
important there's no doubt that wearing
masks protects you and gets you to be
protected so it's people protecting each
other anything that furthers the use of
masks whether it's giving out free masks
or any other mechanism I am thoroughly
in favor of and I just want to echo that
the senator in my opening statement
again I've called on an environment that
we have universal masks
I think it's fundamentally most
important thing we can do that's great
but when you refer to a quote-unquote
universal masks which I agree with you
on would you be supporting the increased
production of high-quality masks and
basically distributing free of charge to
every household in America because I
think that's gonna save tens of
thousands of lives would you agree so
senator Sanders this is a breath sure
why yes sir I agree that that that is
very important because we need to
support mask wearing I would also point
out that dr. Cadillac the asper has
contracted for hundreds of millions of
cloth face coverings - that could be
distributed around the country and those
kinds of processes are being thought of
when I'm not in uniform I wear them
they're white they work very effective
and I think they're a great investment
for the American people
good thank you very last question it's
an issue I've raised now for the last
couple of months all of us hope to god
that a good safe vaccine will be
developed as soon as possible but that
vaccine may not mean anything to a
low-income person who might not be able
to afford it
I happen to believe that we should make
these vaccines and by the way as you all
know federal government our tax dollars
are going to the tune of billions of
dollars into drug companies to help
develop this vaccine that's okay but
don't you Duke would you agree with me
and after that kind of investment we
should make sure that every American
every person in this country can get a
vaccine regardless of their income yes
anybody want to comment on that yes
senator yes senator okay thank you all
very much thank you senator Sanders
senator Paul thank you
fatal conceit is the concept that
central planning with decision making
concentrated in a few hands can never
fully grasp the millions of complex
individual interactions occurring
simultaneously in the marketplace it is
a fatal conceit to believe any one
person or small group of people has the
knowledge necessary to direct an economy
or dictate public health behavior I
think government health experts during
this pandemic need to show caution in
their prognostications it's important to
realize that if society meekly submits
to an expert and that expert is wrong a
great deal of harm may occur when we
allow one man's policy or one group of
small men and women to be foisted on an
entire nation
take for example government experts who
continue to call for schools and day
care to stay closed or that recommend
restrictions that make it impossible for
a school to function for a time there
may not have been enough information
about coronavirus and children but now
there is there are examples from all
across the United States in the world
that showed that young children rarely
spread the virus let's start in Europe
22 countries have reopened their schools
and have seen no discernible increases
in cases these graphs behind me show
nose
Serg when school's open the red line is
where the schools opened there is data
from Austria Belgium Denmark France
Germany Netherlands no spike when
schools are opened contact tracing
studies in China Iceland
Britain and the Netherlands failed to
find a single case of child to adult
infection here at home child care for
essential workers continued to be
available in some states throughout the
pandemic Brown University researchers
collected data on daycares that remained
open during the pandemic over twenty
five thousand kids in their study found
that only 0.16 percent got Kovan and
when you looked at the confirmed cases
for staff there was about one percent of
more than 9,000 staff the YMCA also has
put forward statistics forty thousand
kids at 1,100 sites there were no
reports of coronavirus outbreaks or
clusters dr. Joshua Sharfstein of Johns
Hopkins writes there is converging
evidence that the corona virus doesn't
transmit among children like the flu
that it is a lower risk just yesterday
the american academy of petri at
Pediatrics says we got to get kids back
in school we want them physically
president school they even cite mounting
evidence that children are less likely
to contract the virus ultimately this
all comes down to the fatal conceit that
central planners have enough knowledge
somehow to tell a nation of 330 million
people what they can and can't do
perhaps our planners might think twice
before they weigh in on every subject
perhaps our government experts might
hold their tongue before expressing the
opinion whether we can play NFL football
or major league baseball not in October
perhaps our experts might think twice
before telling the whole world that a
covert vaccine likely won't provide herd
immunity we don't know why I weigh in
with these opinions that we have no
knowledge of these are forecasts that
may well be wrong
perhaps our experts might consider the
undue fear they are instilling in
teachers who are now afraid to go back
to work no one knows the answers to
these questions we shouldn't presume
that a group of experts somehow knows
what's best for everyone
Hayek had it right only decentralized
power and decision-making based on
millions of individualized situations
can arrive at what risks and behaviors
each individual should choose that's
what America was founded on not a herd
with a couple of people in Washington
all telling us what to do and we'd like
sheep blind they follow this all begs
the question what are we going to tell
the people the truth that it's okay to
take their kids back to school
dr. Falchi every day virtually every day
we seem to hear from you things we can't
do but when you're asked can we go back
to school I don't hear much certitude at
all I hear well maybe it depends all of
this body of evidence about schools
around the world shows there's no surge
all of the evidence shows that it's rare
I mean we've so politicized this and
made it politically correct that the
whu-oh releases that it's rare and you
have a scientist up there honestly
giving her opinion what happens to her
she's blackballed and her report that
she refers to was taken off the website
when you go to that that scientist
speech in you and you try to lick clink
on the lick the w-h-o has now screened
it from us because it said something
that's not politically correct at guess
what it's rare for kids to transmit this
but I hear nothing of that coming from
you
all I hear doctor foul cheese we can't
do this we can't do that we can't play
baseball even that's not based on the
science
I mean flu season peaks in February we
don't know that kovat is gonna be like
the flu season it might well we don't
know that but we wouldn't we wouldn't
ban school in October you might close
some schools when they get the flu we
need to not mean to so from sumptuous
that we know everything but my question
to you is can't you give us a little bit
more on schools that we can get back to
school that there's a great deal of
evidence and it's actually good good
evidence the kids aren't transmitting
this it's rare and that kids are staying
healthy and yes we can
open our schools it's the Chairman do I
have a little bit of time to give you a
little thank you so much yeah so very
quickly Senator Paul I I agree with a
lot of what you say about you know this
idea about people having to put their
opinions out without data and sometimes
you you have to make extrapolations
because you're in a position where you
need to at least give some sort of
recommendation but if you were listening
and I think you were to my opening
statement and my response to one of the
questions I feel very strongly we need
to do whatever we can to get the
children back to school so I think we
are in Lock agreement with that the
other thing that I'd like to clarify
very briefly is that I when things get
in the press of what I supposedly said I
didn't say I never said we can't play a
certain sport what happens is that
people in the sport industry they could
either be people from players
association owners people involved in
the health of the plays ask me opinions
regarding certain facts about the spread
of the virus what the dynamics are I
give it and then it gets interpreted
that I'm saying you can't play this
sport well you can't play that sport I
agree with you I am completely
unqualified to tell you whether you can
play a sport or not the only thing that
I can do is to the best of my ability
give you the facts and the evidence
associated with I know about this
outbreak thank you thank you we just
need more optimism there mr. chairman
very much for the hearing and I want to
thank our witnesses for their public
service mr. chairman let me start with
dr. Hahn and then I'll move to Admiral
gerar dr. Hahn I wanted to ask you about
vaccines and as your testimony indicates
and as we've been discussing over time
as researchers work to develop vaccines
to protect against Kovan 19 it's
important that the final
FDA approves have the full confidence of
the American people a vaccine doesn't
help but people don't choose to in fact
be vaccinated so my first question is
given that we've seen very high rates of
both vaccine refusal as well as
skepticism what role can the FDA play in
the coming months to earn the public's
trust that the Cova 19 vaccines are safe
and effective that's question number one
what role the FDA play and then the
second question is what steps can you
take as FDA Commissioner to bolster
public confidence Thank You senator for
that question I couldn't agree more that
public confidence in vaccines is so
important so to your first question we
have an obligation to use all of our
scientific knowledge our regulatory
framework to ensure that any vaccine
that comes before us whether for
authorization or approval meets our
stringent standards for safety and
effectiveness one of the reasons that we
issued that guidance that I mentioned in
my opening statement was to provide
regulatory clarity around what FDA
expects with respect to those data we
want to see certain parts of those data
so that we can demonstrate to the world
to the nation's the American people that
we are following our rigorous standards
with respect to safety and efficacy the
other thing that we've done is draw a
very bright line between FDA and our
regulatory independence and all the
sponsors who are putting forth vaccine
applications to us and that includes
operation warp-speed
so we are providing technical assistance
to those sponsors but we are not part of
the decision-making process and we will
maintain our regulatory independence I
will not prejudge the agency will not
prejudge any decision with respect to
this we will use the science and the
data with respect to what I can do
personally senator I commit to you that
I will continue to be a voice
emphasizing the regulatory independence
we have a number of communications in
progress to communicate to the American
people that the standards were going to
apply
old our firm they are rooted in science
and data and that they will ensure that
we meet the usual high standards of FTA
with respect to safety and efficacy
thanks very much dr. I might submit a
question for the record to dr. Redfield
as well but just so I can get my second
question and to the Admiral I don't want
to ask you about testing and insurance
coverage testing as you know and as
we've emphasized in these hearings is so
fundamental in order to prevent the
spread of copán 19 Congress I think
acted upon that knowledge by mandating
full coverage of Cova 19 diagnostic and
antibody testing both in the families
first bill as well as the cares Act we
made it clear that Americans shouldn't
have to pay a dime for kovin 19 testing
but we're hearing alarming reports of
people not being tested often for one of
two reasons because they're under the
impression they will have to pay for
testing and patients who have been
tested or receiving surprise medical
bills the administration has issued
guidance that appears to be in conflict
with congressional intent in public
health guidance and so we have some
confusion here I'd ask you Admiral can
you assure the American people that the
Department of Health and Human Services
will fulfill the intent of both the
families first bill in the cares Act and
ensure that American the American people
will be provided wide access to cover 19
tests without cost or limitation so
thank you senator and I want to thank
all of you for emphasizing the
importance of testing and eliminating
any barriers that there could be I can't
speak for the department I certainly
speak as the assistant secretary and as
the testing person that we firmly
believe and support the concept of
no-cost testing there should not be a
disincentive in any single way to get
the diagnostic tests that you need to
get tested during screening or so
or the serology tests as Congress
intended so thank you for that we do
need to keep getting that message out
it's a very important one to have thank
you
Thank You mr. chairman Thank You senator
Casey senator Collins thank you very
much mr. chairman
and I want to thank all of our witnesses
today for your dedication and hard work
it's really been important the chairman
raised a very important question about
who pays for the testing when a person
has no symptoms and no known exposure to
the virus and I would add another key
question and that is how are such tests
even access these are critical questions
for the reopening of schools and for the
thousands of jobs in the tourism
industry upon which means economy
depends in Maine for tourists to come
and visit bad out-of-state visitor one
option is to show a recent negative
kovat test the problem is that when
hotel owners in Maine surveyed testing
sites in ten states they found that
ninety percent of requests for a test
for travel purposes were denied now bit
slack come back such two tests is
devastating for reopening Maine's
tourism businesses one innkeeper told me
that last year in the month of June she
had an occupancy rate of 94% this year
it was 6% so you can imagine the impact
on employment at that Inn given the
impact on reopening schools and on jobs
in the tourism and other industries how
is the federal government working with
States to better match demand for
testing with supply and to overcome
these Geographic variations Admiral I
would direct that question to you so
thank you ma'am I will try to be brief
and not to take much of your time but we
were very careful in our prioritization
that we do prioritize persons without
symptoms who are prioritized by health
departments or clinicians for any reason
including public health monitoring
surveillance or screening of other
asymptomatic individuals according to
state local plans so that is a priority
that if it is important for the state
those asymptomatic individuals can be
can be screened the the second issue
just again to be brief is we work we
have worked individually with every
single state to determine what their
state testing needs are how are they
organizing in the context of the CDC and
we are supplying them with the supplies
they need to meet that so every week
shipments of the basic supplies go to
every single state according to their
state testing plans and we keep a little
bit in reserve right because when
there's an outbreak somewhere that we
need to surge we do have that so for
example the state testing goals for July
or somewhere across the country about
thirteen point nine million tests is
there first-line goals and we we will
match those state-by-state I hope that
you will help us get that word out to
testing sites in states from which a lot
of tourists usually come to Maine that
would be very helpful to us doctor
Falchi let me turn to you earlier this
month higher education leaders in Maine
issued a framework for safely returning
to campuses this fall that recognizes
the importance of testing and the need
to include finding
ashlee struggling institutions in
partnerships in order to make sufficient
testing protocols possible you'd last
week spoke about the possibility of the
development of pool testing strategies
and as I understand this what this would
allow more people to be tested using
fewer resources and the medical director
of Stanford's clinical biology lab
suggests that this makes particular
sense in areas with low rates of COBIT
19:00 where you would expect the large
majority of tests to be negative could
you expand on the possibility of
expanding pull testing and tell us more
about that
yes thank you for the question senator
what that really is if you want to get a
feel for the penetrance of infection in
a community rather than testing multiple
each individual person which takes
resources and times what you do and you
can do a statistical analysis of not
losing sensitivity by pooling let's say
ten or fifteen or five together so you
put all the tests together and you do
one test if that test is negative then
you know those ten people are all
negative so instead of utilizing ten
tests you've utilized one test then you
get another batch of we'll say ten or so
and if you then find one is positive
then you go back track and figure out
who that person is and if you do the
mathematical calculation you can save a
lot of time a lot of resources and use
the testing for a variety of other
things that you would need so it's a
really good school it can be used in any
of a number of circumstances at the
community level or even in school if you
wanted to do that so apropos of what you
started your comment off with it clearly
can be extrapolated to that thank you so
much that sounds like an excellent
technique for our school
to use Thank You senator Collins senator
Baldwin Thank You mr. chairman I want to
thank all of our witnesses today for
joining us like so many members of this
committee I'm concerned about new
outbreaks and increasing cases certainly
I've seen them in my home state of
Wisconsin and I know we're seeing that
nationally now CDC and OSHA have issued
recommended safety guidance for
businesses but this guidance is not
enforceable many businesses are truly
trying to do the right thing and
protecting workers and customers and the
public that interacts with those
businesses and so I we also had a
previous discussion I think senator
Sanders raised the issue of American
Airlines filling up their planes versus
others that are still not trying to push
to do so because of safety concerns we
also had I think was Admiral Gerrard
pulled up the what he called critical
guidance please follow this critical
guidance so dr. Redfield should we be
supporting businesses that have taken
the steps to protect their workers and
customers by fully implementing CDC's
and OSHA's recommended safety guidance
yes or no yes yes we should be
supporting those businesses now can you
confirm yes or no that all businesses
have adopted and implemented this
guidance as they've opened up I think
senator you know that unfortunately
that's not been the case
so it's an uneven playing field and it
hurts businesses that are trying to do
the right thing by voluntarily adopting
CDC and OSHA safety guidelines because
their competitors don't have to incur
the same safety and health costs and if
you believe that we should be supporting
the good actors then shouldn't we create
a level playing field by issuing an
emergency temporary standard to require
all businesses to adopt
and comply with enforceable safety
standards I made two comments senator
first one it's so important that we've
tried to say is that this is a time that
everyone in our nation accept the
responsibility that dr. pouchy and I
spoke about to recognize they have the
fundamental responsibility not just to
protect themselves to protect others by
the social distance face mask and
hand-washing secondly again as we look
at the local jurisdictions again to see
where in fact that enforceability would
be whether it's in the local health
department the state health department
or the federal health department I think
again we see that the community can get
behind that responsibility those
businesses that support that
responsibility may find in fact their
business is better than those businesses
that don't I can tell you that my time
is limited the the panel right now is
composed of people representing public
health and public health institutions
OSHA is our lead federal agency for
protecting worker safety and health
have you had communication with the
Department of Labor and OSHA about
issuing mandatory enforceable standards
rather than this voluntary guidance
secretary Scalia is a member of the task
force and he's in the discussions with
us that the vice-president chairs that
specific topic yes we have not had a
discussion directly but we have had
discussions and review of the guidance
that we put two businesses both critical
infrastructure and non critical
infrastructure businesses with OSHA so I
I have limited time left but I do want
to say that the University of Wisconsin
announced
they will be reopening for classes in
the fall they've released a plan called
start smart restart it calls for about
2,000 tests per week on campus
they'll need supplies to do this
including PPE reagents and swabs and
every hearing uncovered 19 we've heard
about shortages of these supplies and
it's why I introduced the medical supply
transparency and delivery act to unlock
the full authority of the defense
production act to increase production of
critical supplies the things that are
needed to conduct widespread testing
Admiral jawar can you describe how
you're working to make sure that
universities and others will have access
to these supplies needed to conduct this
testing in the fall thank you so much
senator and I want to communicate this
begin I'm happy to work with any
University we coordinate what we give to
the states through the state plan so
it's very important that universities
coordinate through the states and we
supply those materials directly to a
single point of contact in the state who
distributes them um we you know we've
been through a lot but we have a lot of
swabs now partially because of increased
domestic production using the DPA
we're distributing about 20 million
swabs per month we're going to do a lot
more than that um so reagents we do not
purchase centrally because the market is
a little bit more mature so we can trust
with an allocation strategy that we
allocate we support the allocation to
different states depending on their
needs
so we've mapped every single machine in
every single state every single County
every single city and unfortunately
there's not enough of one thing that
everybody if they want that can get it
so we really do a matching game to
understand specific state needs for
example in Alaska it is very rural and
there's very limitations to what they
have so we need to make sure they get
what they absolutely need versus other
states that can be a little bit more
flexible so we do have the
I'm afraid we're I'm so well over well
over time we have a large number of
senators who want to ask questions so I
would renew my request that senators and
witnesses try to keep the questions and
answers within within five minutes
senator Cassidy hey thank you gentlemen
for all that you're doing I have a
couple slides can you can I ask the
staff to show the first two slides so
here it shows that we're doing poorly
relative to the countries that are doing
the best and you can argue that Taiwan
is much smaller than week but Taipei is
a very congested City so consider our
cities just collection Taipei's for
example then our Seoul cat South Korea's
it would suggest that what we are
currently doing is less robust unless
whatever adjective you want to use in
the countries that are doing at best
could I have the next slide please
and so this is developed out of a group
by a harbor and just so I can put a plug
in it they will be speaking in our round
table we have Thursday morning and you
can get details from my office if you
wish but kind of that interplay between
kolecki doing the testing tracing those
you know compiling your data and knowing
where your hotspots are and then Tracy
and everyone on this panel knows how
it's done and you mentioned that you're
going to have a strategy that's coming
out later on if it does beg the question
why is it been so long and I'm not
accusing I'm just curious but this has
been developed you can take the slide
down please so knowing that you're going
to develop the strategy and and kind of
build upon senator Burr mentioned what
is the goal of the strategy is the goal
of the strategy to achieve suppression
that's number one and number two what
metrics will you use and knowing that
CDC is the one who really gives guidance
to state and local governments I'm
hoping dr. Redfield since I'll direct
this to you that
won't be up for the states and locals to
put this plan together but it'll be the
considerable intellectual firepower of
the CDC it gives a pretty detailed if
you have this kind of community this is
what you do if you have that community
that is what you do because that's the
kind of role that CDC is expected to
play dr. Redfield any thoughts on this
thank you very much senator a very
important question first John your first
slide just as a quick comment and I'll
try to be quick I think it's really
important because it doesn't illustrate
back to the comment that we tried to
make of the importance of personal
responsibility to really practice the
social distancing and quickly because I
have limited time that's a given but
there has to be a testing aspect of this
because people don't you awaken people
to their responsibilities if they know
they've been exposed if they don't know
they've been exposed they tend to be
more complacent so please focus upon the
testing data and tracking us but yes
senator initially obviously they can was
early case identification contact
tracing and isolation obviously testing
and contact tracing without isolation
has little value the challenge has been
when we learned in March that this virus
is significantly a symptomatically
transmissible then therefore requiring
alternative strategies the strategy that
we're evaluating now is more of a
community led testing strategy where you
go into a broader community and you
actually test a wide number of
individuals as opposed to but do you
have are you following is there a
specific strategy that's going to be
given to state and locals how to
implement this that's very high level
what we need is granularity that's my
question you know we did the initial
strategy and as I said we're currently
evaluating this community test ledge
strategy in a number of communities now
the metrics are simple it's the percent
cases that are positive we were doing
well there for a while you know there
but of course if you take the entire
city of New Orleans or Shreveport you're
going to have some that are hotspots and
some that are really fairly safe
and so I'm guess I'm pointing to the
granularity you know should it be a
census track should it be a hot spot a
building with multifamily housing etc is
frustrated because when I speak to my
state locals they're not getting that
granularity from CDC that seems to be
where we get to where Seoul South Korea
is and I've not yet heard that as kind
of what we're doing we're sharing right
now at the county level the exact
kinetics we have about 130 counties in
this country out of the more than 5,000
of more than 3,000 are having trouble
and continuing to get that granularity I
think you said it senator it's critical
it's got to be a very local focal
response at the ground level right dr.
Redfield do we have that granularity
we've been at this for three months
we've got all these data systems we know
where the people live who are tested you
know we have a federated system which
you alluded to earlier is the plan
coming out tonight this afternoon going
to implement that granularity I'm over
time but if you would allow mr. chairman
for an answer then I'll cease my comment
would be that's where we're going with
that granularity we appreciate some of
the changes in reporting to CDC in terms
of testing that Congress recently did we
are now looking at the granular level we
don't disagree with the premise behind
you
it's that granular response to control
those mini outbreaks which is going to
be fundamental to get this under control
thank you senator senator Cassidy
senator Murphy thank you very much mr.
chairman mr. chairman if this were the
policy of the United States of America
the recommendations and guidelines being
given by our panelists today we would
likely not be in the situation we are
with a virus back on the March spreading
at rapid rates throughout big parts of
the country the problem is our four
panelists do not set the policy of the
United States of America the President
of the United States does and so while
our panelists tell us about the
importance of wearing masks the
president of the United States is
retweeting articles for example entitled
mandatory masks are
about safety they're about social
control he retweets people that are
criticizing how folks look when they
wear masks though our panelists today
are telling us about the effectiveness
of social distancing the president
United States is holding rallies all
across the country in which he
deliberately prevents people from
distancing his staff ripped signs off of
chairs encouraging people to separate
from each other
the president's allies are out there on
TV every day saying that wearing masks
are dehumanizing somebody said the other
day a member of the House that viruses
do what viruses do the only way you're
gonna get immunity is to get exposed
these are the president's allies trying
to curry favor with him and so we have
these two parallel messaging operations
and I just think it's worth stipulating
that everything we're hearing today is
responsible is based on evidence but the
agencies represented here today have
social-media followings of about five
million people the president United
States as a social media following of 82
million and so you can understand why
folks are confused out there they hear
the recommendations from dr. Fauci and
dr. Redfield but then they hear the
president United States criticizing a
reporter for wearing a mask because that
reporter is being social is being
politically correct that's why we're in
the position we're in today where you
see large numbers of people not
complying with recommendations because
they're hearing something very different
from the chief executive and they're
watching him behave in a manner and
encourage behavior that is directly
contrary to what we're being told today
and it just probably requires saying
that out loud at this hearing let me ask
a few questions mr. chairman if I can
about global public health because we
haven't covered that here today dr.
Fauci this virus got here really quickly
and what we learned is that well
restrictions can help or give you time
they can't fully prevent a disease from
arriving here and so even if we do turn
the corner in the United States in a
meaningful way so long as this virus
exists in large quantities outside of
the United States we are still
vulnerable is that right that's correct
sir
and so dr. Redfield um what is your
understanding of why the United States
has not joined the global vaccine effort
why are we not in something like sefie
an organization that is working with
other nations to try to coordinate not
only the development of the vaccine but
also the distribution of the vaccine
well I think the US has obviously
developed an aggressive comprehensive
program but senator it wouldn't preclude
being part of these international
organizations also from my perspective
we have legislation pending right now
before the Foreign Relations Committee
that would put the United States into
these global vaccine efforts it just
doesn't make a lot of sense to many of
us on both sides of the aisle as to why
the Trump administration has not joined
and finally Admiral I'm just maybe help
us understand what our relationship with
the w-h-o is today right around the time
that the president declared that we were
pulling out of the w-h-o not just that
we were not going to fund it but his
announcement was actually we were gonna
sever our relationship of the wh o you
are confirmed to a seat on the executive
board and so have you been recalled from
the wh o are you attending meetings are
you participating what are the details
surrounding our withdrawal from the wh o
which by the way is maybe one of the
most dangerous things in my opinion that
the administration has done in the
middle of a global pandemic what's
what's our status and what's your status
ISM as a confirmed member of that board
so thank you senator and I really do
appreciate the confirmation I was
confirmed on that May 7th and I did
attend the Executive Board on May 22nd
the Executive Board it was virtual it
did participate and support our our
multilateral commitment
I have not been recalled I have not been
given any direction to recall myself in
any way there would be another executive
board a meeting probably in October and
I believe all of us on our public health
standards still work with the w-h-o as a
wh o partner for example we participated
with a wh o on a global sickle-cell
meeting just two days ago so we work we
certainly work from the public health
aspects direction on the official
whether we're going to be a member or
whether I'm not going to go the
executive board I have not gotten that
direction yet okay thank you the
announcement was that we're terminating
our relationship to wh o so probably
some additional clarification would be
helpful Thank You mr. chairman thank you
senator Murphy senator Murkowski Thank
You mr. chairman and gentlemen thank you
for not only your testimony today but
all that you have been doing I think
I've had conversations with each one of
you about the Alaska specific issues
most notably with regards to our our
seafood processing this is the time of
year where we typically welcome a
million-plus tourists as well as as many
thousands that come up from from the
lower 48 and other places to help with
our seafood processing and it has been
very anxious time I think for all of us
in Alaska as we see Outsiders coming in
we have seen obviously elevated cases of
confirmed
Kovan our numbers I think are enviable
when when other states look at us to
know that we're working about 500 active
cases right now about double that in
terms of what we have seen throughout
this whole pandemic but again we know
and you have stated that we don't have
resources that we can look to to
neighboring states we're kind of on our
own island there in terms of resourcing
so what you have done to help facilitate
whether it's the the plans with the
seafood processors the guidance the the
ability to to come in on an as
needed if the situation so demands we
appreciate that we have seen the benefit
of how these very rigorous plans have
have worked an individual who comes up
to to work in a seafood processing
facility is is tested before they come
to the state they're tested when they
get to the state they're put in a 14-day
quarantine we have seen positive cases
once people have arrived but we've been
able to do what the plan calls for which
is that contact tracing and then
isolation and keeping things to a
minimum so I think it does demonstrate
that these tough plans really can work
they are expensive though if you are
bringing in several hundred or perhaps a
thousand workers and you have to put
them up in a hotel for 14 days with pay
when you have to provide for the health
protocols this is this is costly I would
ask for for your input and probably a
question for the record just in terms of
which agencies can can best help
facilitate these seafood processors with
not only implementation of the specific
guidance but how we can be dealing with
the costs we do receive some benefit
from the discretionary funds provided to
the states but I think we would all
recognize like the meat pot meat packing
facilities our seafood processors aren't
important in a critical industry not
only to Alaska but to the country so we
want to work to to address that I do
want to speak very quickly though to the
the public health infrastructure I'm
told that in Alaska as we are doing our
contract taste tracing it is still a
paper copy Excel spreadsheet faxed to
the epidemiology labs this is how we're
doing our tracing I thought well maybe
that's just Alaska and I'm told by by
dr. Zink who you have all had
conversations with that well this is
actually going on in in cow
for Nia as well that to me is not a
contract tape contact tracing system
that works and is sufficient so I want
to ask about not only your view of the
sufficiency of of contact tracing and
this is probably to you dr. Redfield but
then dr. pouchy I want to ask you about
the concern that we have with certain
certain parts of the country where you
have public mistrust of vaccines in
general my fear is that we may get to
the place where we will get to that
place where we have that successful
vaccine but we still have the concern
from many and a mistrust and whether
it's vaccine hesitation or vaccine
confidence I don't know what the buzz
word is but I'm worried that we don't
have a plan for how to deal with that so
first contact tracing and then the
vaccine thank you very much senator I
think it's really important just to
highlight what you said about the
current state of data systems for Public
Health in the United States that they
really are in need of aggressive
modernization and again thank Congress
for the funding there but it is a
substantial investment that needs to
take place there are a number of
counties that are still doing this pen
and pencil as you commented and we need
to have a comprehensive integrated
public health data system that's not
only able to do something that's in real
time but actually it can be predictive
and it would be one of the great I think
investments of our time to make that
happen once and for all
and that's really fundamental to be able
to operationalize contact tracing etc
and contact tracing in this case they'll
be very quick really doesn't have any
value unless you can do it in real time
it doesn't help like I just did with the
airlines where we had people that were
flying infected from Afghanistan and we
didn't get the information till day 14
day 15 day 16 it's irrelevant so again
we love the partnership to get an
integrated public health data system not
just for CDC but for all of our
jurisdictions
across the nation into one timely
integrated system senator thank you for
the question about if you can be
succinct we're well over time we'll be
quick we have a community engagement
program that is embedded within the
sites where the vaccine trials will be
done because we're thoroughly aware of
what you're concerned about and it is a
reality a lack of trust of authority a
lack of trust in government and a
concern about vaccines in general we
need to engage the community by boots on
the ground and getting community
particularly those populations that have
not always been treated fairly by the
government minority populations
african-americans Latinos and Native
Americans and we have a program that's
already operable right now to do that
thank you
Thank You senator Murkowski senator
Warren oh thank you very much mr.
chairman dr. Falchi you came before the
help committee seven weeks ago to
discuss the country's response to the
Kovach 19 and at the time you told me
that the u.s. did not quote by any means
have total control over this outbreak
you also told me that we were quote
going in the right direction now on the
day you testified before the committee
that was May 12 2020 there were about
21,000 new cases of corona virus
yesterday there were about 40 thousand
new cases of corona virus dr. Fauci do
these numbers show that the country is
still moving quote in the right
direction and that the corona virus
pandemic is under control
well I think the numbers speak for
themselves although we do have a number
of parts of the country to doing well
I'm very concerned about what's going on
right now particularly in the four
states that are accounting for about 50%
of the new infections but the other
vulnerable states so I'd have to say the
numbers speak for themselves I'm very
concerned and I'm not satisfied with
what's going on because we're going in
the wrong direction
if you look at the curves of the new
cases so we've really got to do
something about that and we need to do
it quickly
short answer that question is that
clearly we are not in total control
right now thank you thank you very much
now our case numbers are getting worse
and our death rates are going to get
worse soon during this same period of
time some other countries around the
world have controlled the virus they're
reporting fewer cases each day and they
are able to provide targeted testing and
to keep it up so that they can tell
what's happening and follow up if there
is an outbreak in other words
controlling the coronavirus can be done
but because of bad federal leadership we
have not been able to do this here in
the United States so dr. Fauci the last
time you were before this committee you
told me that if the u.s. did not have
quote an adequate response that the
country would quote have the deleterious
consequences of more infections and more
deaths now I know that we've made some
progress but half measures won't save
lives
dr. pouchy I'm asking you to be very
direct with all of us on this if we
don't fully implement the widespread
testing contact tracing programs and
social distancing practices that
everyone seems to agree that we need can
we expect these spikes and infection to
keep happening in different places
around the country Thank You senator I'm
always direct with you and I'll tell you
in direct answer to your question that
if you look at what's going on and just
look at some of the film clips that
you've seen of people congregating often
without masks of being in crowds and
jumping over and avoiding and not paying
attention to the guidelines that we very
carefully put out we're gonna continue
to be in a lot of trouble and there's
going to be a lot of hurt if that does
not stop and that
get our act together more and more
communities around the country are going
to see these dangerous surges of over 19
doctor found you back in March
you also said well looking at what we're
seeing now you expected there to be
between a hundred thousand and two
hundred thousand coronavirus deaths and
millions of infections in aul so let's
flash forward to late June here we are
at the end of June we've already seen a
hundred and twenty six thousand deaths
with infection rates rising rapidly dr.
pouchy based on what you're seeing now
how many covered 19 deaths and
infections should America expect before
this is all over I can't make an
accurate prediction but it is going to
be very disturbing I will guarantee you
that because when you have an outbreak
in one part of the country even though
in other parts of the country they're
doing well they are vulnerable I made
that point very clearly last week at a
press conference we can't just focus on
those areas that are having the surge it
puts the entire country at risk we are
now having 40-plus thousand new cases a
day I would not be surprised if we go up
to a hundred thousand a day if this does
not turn around and so I am very
concerned can you make any kind of
estimate on what we're looking at
overall on the number of deaths before
this is over you made an estimate back
in March between a hundred thousand and
two hundred thousand but week a lot more
information now and we're already at a
hundred and twenty six thousand dollars
again I can't make a estimation because
that would have to be modeled out
because when models are done and that's
where those original numbers came from
senator as I've said very often models
are as good as the assumptions that you
put into the model and those assumptions
often change depending upon what your
response is so I would really be
hesitant to give a number that will come
back and either be contradicted and
overblown or
the blown but I think it's important to
tell you and the American public that
I'm very concerned because it could get
very bad all right I appreciate that
doctor foul chief what we all I just
like the same time that my Republican
colleague Scott because Senator Warren I
always treat you fairly and I would
appreciate your respecting the
Chairman's rules if you'd like to make a
closing statement go ahead and do it I
don't appreciate your thank you question
in presiding over the year that you were
allowing more time since we had such
important witnesses when you're chairman
you and you can you can make that you
can make those decisions thank you you
know I just want to make the point that
we can't keep pretending this virus is
getting better when it isn't that's how
we end up with messes like the situation
in Texas racing to reopen too soon then
scrambling to close down before the
hospital's get completely overwhelmed if
we don't get our act together this is
our future see-sawing back and forth
between two new restrictions and then
exploding cases and repeated shutdowns
in this future thousands more Americans
will die and our economy will be brought
to its knees we've got to have a
national strategy that makes testing
available to every school business every
hospital every church anywhere that
Americans come together we need to
expand contact tracing and we need
leaders starting with President Trump
who have enough backbone to face reality
distribute our resources set our
standards and stick to them because if
we don't the result is going to be more
economic wreckage and more death Thank
You mr. chairman thank you senator
Warren what I've tried to do in the in
this hearing is to ask senators to stay
within five minutes and the answers
within five minutes and if if the
answers go beyond that I've tried to
be respectful of that but - but I would
ask senators not to ask their questions
in - well past five minutes and then
expect to make a speech at the end
senator Scott I'll Thank You mr.
chairman and I will certainly respect
your your time limits I think we all
should do that and frankly as we were
asking dr. Foster for an estimate of how
many lives may be a loss I recall the
first estimates were between 1 and 2.4
million lives so I'm certainly glad that
we are not there and perhaps one of the
reasons why we should be thankful for
where we are now and force ourselves to
have a serious conversation about
continuing to flatten the curve is
because the all-hands-on-deck approach
is effective
we just need as much cooperation from as
many people as conceivably possible in
every state around the country in order
for us to see these numbers continue to
make it dive in the right direction as
the Phocis spike in the wrong direction
and I think about the operations
warp-speed along with the crucial
support from Barda and other federal
agencies other private partnerships and
accelerating groundbreaking technologies
that could eradicate over nineteen and
revolutionize frankly a vaccine
development landscape because of these
efforts by industry academia and
government working in concert we could
see a viable candidate or candidates at
a matter of months for a vaccine and
because of the growing number of
large-scale manufacturing agreements
with companies like moderna Iser and J&J
producing hundreds of millions of doses
at risk which means in advance we are
already working to address issues of
access and this is critical especially
for our most distressed communities that
said affective development and
widespread access while essential are
only part of the equation if and when
and I feel optimistic that it's wind and
not if we get a viable vaccine we need
to encourage folks to choose to get
vaccinated I was really concerned when I
saw a recent AP survey that showed that
only 49 percent of American adults plan
to get back
naded once the Cofield 19 vaccine came
to market a full 20% so that they did
not plan to get vaccinated and one-third
of Americans were not sure given the
public's recent and vital focus on
health disparities is worth noting that
among certain groups these figures are
even more alarming just 25 percent of
black Americans 37 percent of Hispanic
Americans plan to get vaccinated against
the coronavirus my aunt my question to
the full panel what steps can we take at
every level of government and in the
private sector with health care
providers to ensure a proactive
education campaign and outreach strategy
on the importance of getting vaccinated
both for kovat 19 and frankly even more
broadly I'll take a shot at it first
senator as I mentioned in response to
another question that we have a
community engagement program that
actually operates out of operation
warp-speed the vaccine development
program component of that also there
needs to be engagement of people who the
community trusts particularly
individuals who are noted sports figures
over metha when we were involved and
continue to be involved in community
engagement with HIV we used people in
the community boots on the ground to go
out who looked and lived and are like
the people they're trying to engage it's
very critical because I share with you
the concern that we get to the hoop and
we get through it of getting a safe and
effective vaccine only to find that a
substantial proportion of the population
do not want to get vaccinated a
particular concern is it's that
proportion of the population that
generally are the most vulnerable in the
sense of the minority communities
African Americans latina --xe
Native Americans who in fact because of
underlying conditions make it more
likely that if they do get infected they
would have a poor outcome so it's
extremely important to engage
them at the local level thank you thank
you very much for your answer dr. Conte
let me disclose with my 40 seconds that
I have left and respecting the time and
I hope that we continue to do so the
patent the pandemic has triggered a drop
of 60 to 80 percent of immunization
rates among children and even now that
states are reopening we're not seeing
the rebound in these rates as that that
are necessary
this creates a real risk of secondary
infections and disease outbreaks that
are not on the general public's radar as
we reckon with the chief crisis at hand
so I think it's incredibly important
that we follow your strategy
dr. Falchi as it relates to engaging
community leaders and perhaps people
with notoriety to challenge us to get
involved in taking the vaccines Thank
You mr. chairman I apologize for being
four seconds over my time Thank You
senator Scott for respecting the time we
have eight senators remaining who have
questions and we should have time for
all of them to have a chance to ask a
question senator Kaine Thank You mr.
chair and thank you to the witnesses dr.
Fauci I saw an interview with you last
week where you talked about a concern
that there's two sizable a percentage of
our population that sort of done like
science and scientists and advice from
scientists and I hear real emotion in
your voice as you express concern about
people gathering in large groups and
without masks and I gather that's the
kind of anti science the concern that
you were worrying about when you had
that interview last week yeah that is
part of its senator yes because the
disregard of recommendations that come
from authorities only because it's a
recommendation I think the attitude of
pushing back from Authority and pushing
back on scientific data is very
concerning we're in the middle of a
catastrophic outbreak and we really do
need to be guided by scientific
principles and and this could cause
problems down the road if we get to a
vaccine but people don't want to get the
vaccine so we all have to message this
pretty strongly doctor
redfield I want to thank you I was going
to ask you a question today that I've
been asking over and over again why does
the CDC's guidance for institutions of
higher education not even mention the
word testing but as soon as your
testimony was done this morning the CDC
website changed and there are now
guidelines for the Institute's of higher
education with fairly extensive
recommendations and guidance that
mandates about testing I didn't have a
chance to read them but I saw them
popped up on the CDC website and I
wanted to thank you for that your
testimony dr. Redfield today and some of
the written testimony talks about the
fact that the public health system
relies on timely inaccurate data systems
but that we've under invested in them
and the crisis has quote highlighted the
need to continue efforts to modernize
the public health systems last year I
introduced a bill called the saving
lives through better data Act it was
with Senator Isakson and Senator King
and colleagues were helpful in this we
we were able to get 50 million dollars
in December in the Appropriations deal
and then another five hundred million
dollars in the cares Act but I would
urge my colleagues to do even more
because the request from our public
health communities is significantly more
sizeable I hope we might be able to get
that into the next kovat package doctor
foul Qi this is a challenging question
challenging how to figure it out
the CDC last week said that a new group
that we have to consider at risk is
pregnant women and lactating women the
night's vex
Ramez severe REM severe testing and
vaccine testing often doesn't include
pregnant women I think for some safety
reasons but we would want to make sure
the pregnant and lactating women have
access to treatments and access the
vaccine so how will we be trying to do
research and testing you know the the
women can safely access these treatments
or behinds
that is a great question it applies also
to children so what we're doing with the
vaccine is you do a phase 1 trial in
normal how
the adults not pregnant not children and
you show initial safety then when you
move into this phase two and three
studies if you get even the slightest
glimpse of efficacy and safety in that
population you go back and do a phase
one in pregnant and lactating women as
well as in children and if that is safe
there you bridge the data so that you
could use the efficacy data that you
already started to apply back to
pregnant women I see that's how you do
it let me ask you this at this point is
the nation's goal with respect to
coronavirus to mitigate it or suppress
it you know vaccines right now you're
talking about vaccines so I'm just
talking about what is what is our goal
are we yeah the indicate are we trying
to suppress you know it depends on where
you are there's containment and
mitigation so if you have a level of
virus that's low enough that you can
adequately contain by the standard way
of identification isolation contact
tracing particularly if you make sure
you link the identification with
isolation because if you just do contact
tracing without isolation it's not going
to work when you get into a situation if
I if I could dr. pouchy cuz I don't want
to go over time I want to say just one
thing about testing real quick
Admiral draw when you were here last you
said we would have capacity to do 40 to
50 million tests a month in September
that's about 1.3 to 1.7 million a day on
May 12th we had done about three hundred
and ten thousand yesterday we did five
hundred sixty thousand are we gonna get
to 1.3 - 1.7 million tests a day by
September
so thank you for asking that we will
absolutely have the capacity to do that
it's depending on the need and again as
you might expect a few weeks ago the
need for testing was much less than it
is now we had a good system that it was
actually very good that we were able to
identify an increase in positivity very
early but obviously with the with the
outbreaks we're having now we need to
massively surge testing in those areas
we will have that capability across the
board yeah we'll have that and that's
assuming no pooling when we start
pooling these together three four tests
then you do the math so I'm never going
to be happy until we have more tests
that we never have to say the word tests
again but we're gonna be in reasonably
good shape
given those parameters Thanks thank you
senator Kaine senator Romney Thank You
mr. chairman and thank you to each of
the panelists for the sacrifice and the
effort that you've been making over
these past several years there's some
past summer months as well it here as
you know because we didn't know a great
deal about this virus run on the scene
in America we ask the American people to
do basically shut down their lives cut
back on flying family reunions funerals
church services restaurants bars
theaters everything gets shut down
well now it's ended and hopefully we've
learned something about how this disease
actually spread and the American people
need to go back out there good to go
back out if they are going back out we
saw for instance the lake of the ozarks
all these people and we said oh my
goodness this is going to be a major
problem but my impression was because
people are outside or who knows what
other reason it wasn't to make a major
problem so so my question is this where
is the risk greatest how is it that it's
spreading it is spreading indoors is it
spreading more in restaurants and bars
is it okay to be outdoors and perhaps
not socially distance as our family
reunion is okay or can you give us some
guidance based on but hopefully we know
as to where the risks are greatest I
know you keep saying social distance and
mass but you know people are getting in
airplanes
they're going to restaurants where is
the risk greatest and where are we
relatively safe you helped us through
that family reunions can we get together
with family reunions outdoors is it
safer outdoors and indoors give us some
guidance can you do that to dr. Falchi
and dr. Redfield Thank You senator I
think first and foremost the most
important thing in that assessment is
knowing at the granular level what the
kinetics of transmission are in that
community as I mentioned we have a
hundred and thirty counties right now in
the United States where we consider them
quote hot spots we have many other areas
whether it's very limited transmission
so first and foremost it's knowing the
if you're in that area of active
transmission then secondly it's it's
knowing what you do when you're in that
area of active transmission and what
what precautions one takes all right
well I think those are the two things I
will say that there's just more and more
data showing that the use of face
coverings and masks are an effective way
to prevent transmission in in these
gatherings and I think we're just going
to come back and tell you the most
important thing you're within a
community with Limited transmission and
you're wearing face masks or there's
significant transmission you're wearing
face masks and you practice those social
distancing hand-washing that's the best
thing best recommendations I can tell
you yeah in addition second outdoor
better than indoor baws really not good
really not God congregation at a bar
inside is bad news we really got to stop
that right now when you have areas that
are surging like we see right now but in
answer to your question a little bit
more granular outdoor is always better
than indoor if your outdoor distance as
Bob said wear a mask if you can but you
can have some social interaction the one
point I want to make very briefly is
that we should not look at the public
health endeavors as being an obstruction
to opening up we should look at it as a
vehicle to opening up
so that you don't want to just restrict
everything because people are not going
to tolerate that so you can get outdoors
you can interact wear a mask try to
avoid the clothes congregation of people
wash your hands often but don't just
make it all on and on we've got to be
able to get people to get out and enjoy
themselves within the safe guidelines
that we have so make public health work
for you as opposed against you I very
much appreciate those those responses I
think it'd be extraordinarily helpful
for all of us as we're going about our
lives if there was data that indicated
where people are getting infected were
they in a bar within a restaurant where
they outdoor outdoors at a pool I've
heard reports that virtually nobody has
been infected if they're outdoors is
that true or not true we given how long
we've been at this we've got to have
more granular data so people know where
they're there's greater risk how many
people for instance have been infected
as we're something flying on airplanes
we have to know that if we can publish
that information for the American people
they will know where they could be safe
and go back of course continuing social
business thing and wearing masks but we
need that data
finally all this hasn't won an answer
who was responsible for distribute the
vaccine what person or what agency
determines how the vaccine when it's
available will be distributed well thank
you senator you this is a central
function of CDC where we really help
with vaccine distribution throughout the
nation childhood back to you thank you
very much senator Romney senator Hasson
well thank you mr. chair and thank you
to all the witnesses for being here and
for the teams you lead I know how hard
everybody is working dr. Redfield I want
to start with a question to you 43% of
the deaths in this country have been in
nursing homes or long-term care
facilities in my state of New Hampshire
80% of our deaths are attributed to
residents of nursing homes and long-term
care facilities
in mid-may the White House urged states
to complete COBIT 19 testing on every
nursing home worker and resident within
14 days a month and a half later that
still has not happened cdc has since put
out different guidance on nursing home
testing calling for a baseline test for
residents and weekly testing for nursing
home workers given the widespread
outbreaks within nursing homes and
unique risks posed to residents
what is CDC doing to ensure that states
carry out the recommendations for
nursing home testing issued by CDC On
June 13th and how many states have met
these guidelines so far Thank You
senator we are working in close contact
with CMS on on that issue as you say
we're not an enforcement agency we make
recommendations but but I'm asking and
my time is short I'm asking what what
you are doing to keep track of
compliance with guidelines 43% death
rate nationwide is huge and people are
looking to you all for granular guidance
here so what are you doing to find out
who's in compliance and who's not I was
trying to emphasize that we're working
in partnership with CMS which has that
regulatory oversight we're there to
continue to reinforce the guidance as
you mentioned which we think is critical
and we we think we do have to get
everyone's the screened in these nursing
homes and the employees every week
unfortunately we still think that we
need to keep visitors isolated from the
homes right now particularly in areas
with high jurisdictions but the
regulatory function of this is CMS but
we are really meeting with them daily to
see what more we can do to try to ensure
that there's greater compliance I thank
you for that people are looking to the
CDC for not only very clear and granular
guidelines and you've heard that all
throughout the questioning but
particularly with nursing homes and
long-term care facilities there's a lot
more work to be done and we are still
hearing that they're not getting usable
personal protective equipment all the
time either let me go to another
question and dr. Fatih I'll start with
you we've heard discussion already today
the difference in the effectiveness of
measures taken for instance in Europe in
the United States this is a graph that
shows the disparity between new
confirmed cases per million residents
over the previous seven days between the
United States Europe Canada and Japan
the disparity is i popping surveys
suggest that mask-wearing in the united
states occurs less frequently than in
europe you and our witnesses have been
very clear on the importance of masks
wearing in public places do you
attribute the improvements in Europe to
more widespread use of masks or are
there also other specific aguh vermin
policies or individual behavioral
differences that you believe should be
incorporated into our national strategy
it certainly masks play at role but
there are a number of other multifaceted
things in each of those those very
disturbing graphs that you show one of
the things that became clear when we
shut down as a nation in reality only
about 50% of the nation's shut down with
regard to other things that were allowed
in many of the European countries 90 95
percent of all activities were shut down
so that is one of the reasons why you
saw particularly in Italy which shut
down to a much greater extent than we
did the cases came way down in a sharp
curve downward and then stayed so it's
not only masks it's the fact that the
countries in Europe and the other
countries you have there had a much more
uniform response or a very heterogeneous
country and we had a heterogeneous
response depending whether you are in
the Northeast southern West or what have
you so there's a number of other factors
probably some that we still don't even
understand well thank you and I I'm
gonna move on to just one other issue
and it's really just to urge dr.
Redfield and the CDC to issue additional
guidance for schools in particular on
reopening I understand that you are
continuing to do that I
appreciate that the CDC has released FAQ
frequently asked questions documents on
things like youth sports which provide
more concrete useful information for
families and I'm hoping that you'll do
the same kind of FAQ documents for
parents and teachers that directly
address practical questions and concerns
about school reopening plans simply like
what happens what should a school do
specifically if one or two positive
cases come up in a classroom or in a
teacher what should parents and teachers
expect school administrations to do so
we can follow up with that I appreciate
the chairs and dalton's Thank You
senator Hasson senator Braun Thank You
mr. chairman good two sets of questions
and like for a doctoral foul Qi and red
field give about a minute each to the
first I want to get the broad numbers I
think dr. Redfield you might have been
on a record that you think there's 10
times as many cases out there's and I
know that's a guess I'd like to know
because if that's the case all of a
sudden the fatality rate goes from 5
percent down to 5 10 percent 20 times as
many cases of course two and a half down
to 0.25
what is your start with you dr. Redfield
how many cases you think we actually
have out there and then how many
vaccinations and our herd immunity
combinations as a percentage of our
total population do we need to get to
for this thing to be in the rearview
mirror so we got a few big numbers to
kind of relate the journey ahead thank
you very much senator quickly we now
know that this virus began to really
spread in the United States and in in in
March and in between march and the end
of May you know we've been able to do
antibody testing and that's what allowed
us to understand how many people were
really infected so that during that
period it was our best estimate about 10
to 1 so we're probably talking over 20
million 22 million Americans have been
infected I don't want people to assume
that's the same ratio now in June and
July
going forward because you think it's
more than that no I think it could be
less because we're doing more and more
testing okay but clearly it gives us a
good idea the extent of infection was
more in March April and May and not two
million individuals but more more closer
to 20 million what is your opinion how
many individuals we need vaccinated and
are having herd immunity before this
saying goes into the rearview mirror
yeah Tony me comment on that too it's
it's really got to be over 70 percent of
the population it's got to be immune
before we even see any impact of herd
immunity doctor grouchy not yeah I
totally agree given the transmissibility
which is highly efficient you're gonna
need something somewhere between 70 and
85 percent I would say 70 at the lowest
okay second set of questions would be on
the issue of herd immunity because of
course we've got the we don't know how
long it's gonna take to have an
effective vaccine and I'm guessing when
you're talking about hurt immunity it's
got to actually confer immunity if you
get it and there might be some
uncertainty do get the immunity what is
the how do we go about the approaches
that we've used at this point is herd
immunity gonna be something that you
think will march through if we take the
strategy of having a different approach
for younger people it seemed to have
lower hospitalization rates and less
significant consequences because I think
it's another thing we need to know
because I think that's already gonna be
done by each individual in a way as they
size up their own personal risks so how
much can we count on hurt immunity I can
answer quickly and then turn to Tony I
think it's important to realize even now
we're probably looking at somewhere
between five and eight percent of the
American public has experienced this
virus so for me herd immunity as a basic
strategy you're talking about a
multi-year strategy this is why it's so
important that the alternative strategy
is a biological countermeasure in the
development of a vaccine
one of the issues that might be
complicating I don't think it's gonna be
something that is gonna be any kind of a
showstopper but we've got to realize and
as Senator Paul said we have to be
humble and know there's a lot we don't
know and what we don't know is with the
durability is in other words so if you
wind up getting hurt immunity to 75 80
percent what we need to learn and only
time will teach us this is how long this
immunity lasts is it a year two three
four or is it even less is it months we
don't know when we find out then that
will inform us as to whether or not if
you get a vaccine how off you need to
boost it so we have to realize we don't
really know the answer to your question
in any definitive way at least that
gives some clarity some parameters live
within senator Hasson stressed the point
of protecting the most vulnerable
because to me the one thing it looks
like we could certainly do is to take
that highest risk group from the data
we've already got and build in essence
an iron dome around them as the one
thing that would seem to be the most
important thing to do where you get
certain results and I think that has to
be in place as we the uncertainty of
herd immunity and when we get an
effective vaccine actually converge I
might add just we always think about
herd immunity with regard to natural
infection and or vaccination but when
you want to talk about protecting the
vulnerable we want to see if some of the
other programs that are more
prophylactic treatment programs like
passive transfer of plasma or monoclonal
antibodies or hyper immune globulin
those are some of the things that you
can do to protect the vulnerable until
we do get an effective vaccine thank you
Thank You senator broaden senator Smith
so we need robust surveillance
occupational testing if we are going to
safely reopen our economy and our
schools are
nursing homes and our group homes to
make sure that they're not a conduit for
infection and we're seeing us a good
example of this is in New York State
where employees in nursing homes are
required to get co19 test by sweet
here's the problem if you're a worker
who tastes for that test is that my
employer is it my private insurance I
have insurance or do I have to pay for
it out of my pocket so I'm thinking
about that low-wage worker of working in
childcare or food processing or maybe as
a security worker or janitor and you
know the average cost of a test is
somewhere in the neighborhood of 75 to
150 dollars though there are reports of
people being charged over $6,000 to be
tested assuming you can find a test so
this is my first question last week
federal agencies said that health plans
are not required to cover the full cost
of tests for surveillance or
occupational reasons and the federal
testing plan which talks about the value
of surveillance testing and occupational
testing is silent on this so let me ask
you dr. falchi do you agree that we are
going to be better able to contain the
spread of koban 19 and save lives if we
have surveillance testing no doubt
surveillance testing is going to be a
very important part of the program to
understand not only the current
penetrance of the virus in society but
where it's going short answer to your
question is it's going to be very
important in our public health measure
and would not also the price of these
tests or the ability to pay for these
tests be a pretty significant barrier to
having that happen I think common sense
tells you that if people cannot pay for
it they're not gonna do it and that's
one of the reasons why we got to figure
out how we can do it without having the
stress of people who can't afford it to
be part of that process and of course
you know the worry of course is that
this ability to pay for these
surveillance tests for this kind of
surveillance testing the
could really tend to exacerbate
underlying inequities since a lot of
front line workers and essential workers
who don't have the privilege of working
for home are much more likely to be
black and brown and indigenous people
people of color isn't that right as in
all cases that people who are
economically not able to engage and some
of the things that benefit others they
always in general get a short end of the
stick on that and that's what we have to
be concerned about right right well I
think this is a really important place
where we sure that as we look at our
schools or higher institutions of higher
education coming back but we have the
ability to do this and that the ability
to pay for that test isn't a barrier so
I appreciate it sure Alexander you
mentioned this at the beginning others
of my colleagues have mentioned this
place or we could work together in a in
a constructive way
I wouldn't ask a question specifically
related to vaccines because it's been a
lot of discussion about this a lot of
discussion about how we can make sure
the people trust these vaccines that
they are safe that they were and the
long-term consequences potential
negative side effects we understand
those so let me just ask maybe I'll ask
you again dr. Fauci how do we troll the
vaccine that has only had a short number
of months potentially being tested in
the human body there are a couple of
ways to overcome that first is that you
have a large number of people in the
trial the trials that we're talking
about now we're gonna have 30,000 people
in the trial and maybe even more in some
of them you can get it a considerable
amount of safety data but then there's a
process you know after a vaccine maybe
would show efficacy to do further
studies following licensure availability
let dr. Han maybe comment on that more
because that becomes
something very much involved with the
FDA's Authority and making sure we do
have safe vaccines so Stephen let me
just um if I could maybe put a final
point in this question for you dr. Hahn
I mean what if the manufacturer were to
say that they could get a vaccine to
market in January but only if they were
released from liability
what's the FDA policy on that how would
you resolve that question Thank You
senator so we would not get into the
issue of liability for an individual
sponsor and what we would do and that's
why we released the guidance this
morning is we would ensure that our
normal regulatory approach and our
standards for safety and efficacy are
met so while we're all really that's not
an FDA authority that we would that we
believe running a little late go ahead
with your question but the decision is
here to announce the vaccine in October
of 2020 dr. Hahn can you just tell us
how we can have transparency so that
people can trust that that isn't
happening senator Smith a very good
question and really important and leads
to the issue of public confidence it's
why we released our guidance today we
want to be clear about what the
standards and the data that we'll need
to make a decision and what factors go
into those decision and what the
American people to hear me when I say we
will use the science and data from those
trials and we will we will ensure that
our high levels of the standards for
safety and efficacy are met Thank You
senator Smith senator Leffler
good morning thank you all for being
here sorry I can't be there in person I
wanted to ask dr. Redfield can you
outline what steps the CDC is taking to
you know look at as we prepare for
handling both the flu and kovat 19
season simultaneously this fall I know
the CDC recently developed a test that
diagnoses both koban 19 in the flu but
one of their activities is the agency
engaged in and are there any novel
approaches that you see in terms of
implementing this would love to hear
about the agency's process for
approaching the season this fall and in
your thoughts there thank you very much
senator I think it's really important to
recognize that it is going to be
difficult with flu and kovat this fall
first and foremost is to try to increase
the American public's acceptance of flu
vaccine as you know less than 50%
accepted we're working hard to begin to
reach out particularly to groups that
have been underrepresented to try to
build that confidence in vaccination
we've worked with the manufacturers to
see if they could boost the amount of
vaccine that would be available they've
now increased their commitment to almost
a hundred and eighty nine million doses
CDC bought another 7 point 1 million
doses normally we buy about 500,000 to
be able to be available to the states
and local health departments for
uninsured adults we've now we increased
that to 7 point 1 million doses we've
augmented our commitment to the children
vaccine program anticipating that
there's going to be more children that
will qualify in light of the
unemployment so those are some of the
areas that we've begun to prepare for
thank you and this question is for dr.
Hahn you know the pandemic has exposed
our vulnerabilities in the medical
supply chain and obviously we have a
reliance on imports from country like
China that can quickly pose a national
security risk in the face of an outbreak
of infectious disease
we need to come up with the strategy to
boost our production here both
pharmaceuticals and supplies I've
introduced some legislation titled the
beat China Act to offer incentives to
companies that bring manufacturing back
to the United States but would like to
hear from you what additional steps can
policymakers take to boost our
capability to produce these supplies and
pharmaceuticals domestically thank you
Center Lafleur and thank you for your
leadership on this I think one issue
that we can all agree upon is the lack
of redundancy in the supply chain and
the dependency that we've seen during
the Cova 19 pandemic has been a problem
the agency's primary focus has been on
instilling redundancy in the supply
chain particularly of pharmaceuticals by
diversifying that supply chain and
really looking for opportunities to
encourage domestic manufacturing we of
course on the regulatory side provide
guidance as well as regulations around
the manufacturing specifications to
ensure quality of pharmaceuticals and
other medical products we will continue
to do that particularly in the advanced
manufacturing space in order to
encourage domestic manufacturing we look
forward very much to working with you
and other members of Congress to see how
we can create the proper incentives to
have that redundancy and particularly to
have as much domestic manufacturing as
possible
thank you dr. Hahn no further questions
I'll yield my time thank you senator
left where senator Jones Thank You mr.
chairman thank you all for being here
today I really appreciate your testimony
your consistency over the last few
months it has got to be somewhat
discouraging to all of you as it is to
us to see these numbers I want to kind
of focus a little bit on schools as we
will start opening schools up in Alabama
in August and let me give you a little
chronology here the state of Alabama
kind of began to open up its economy
more and in May a little bit more toward
the end of May and then in for Memorial
Day we saw the photographs and
that doctor Falchi referred to with
everybody just having a big time for my
Memorial Day holiday now at the end of
June we are at our highest levels the
last 14 days have shown over 10,000
cases which is 28 percent of the cases
that we have seen have occurred just in
the last 14 days and at the end of this
week we have the July 4th holiday coming
up and we're gonna see a delay in
hospitalizations from right now if we do
the same thing on July 4th we're going
to have a huge problem at the end of
July and early August when we start
opening schools up our state school
superintendent this week said that it
would cost about 1.8 million dollars for
the average school system to do those
things necessary to try to protect kids
and the faculty but I heard Senator Paul
in his comments and discussing a number
of things to where you would get the
impression that we could just open
schools back up without spending any of
that money
so my question primarily to dr. Falchi
and dr. Redfield could you comment on
some of the statistics and some things
that you heard about children
transmitting this disease and whether or
not we need to spend some additional
monies for our schools to do things like
how have extra PPE to do things like
hiring potentially hiring additional
health officers temperature screenings
those kind of things are those going to
be necessary based on what I've heard
from Senator Paul and what happened on
his charts in other countries dr. fowey
and dr. Redfield
but I'll quickly give it a shot and then
hand it over to dr. Redfield we don't
know precisely I think the data that was
very interesting that Senator Paul
showed about school openings and not
seeing any real obvious surge in cases
is important but we don't really know
exactly what the efficiency of spread is
first of all how many children get
infected
that was the reason why in my opening
statement I mentioned the study that
we're doing at the NIH of 6,000 families
looking at children what is the rate of
their infection and how often do they
infect their face
families because sip is true that the
rate is down we know that they don't get
seriously ill with hospitalizations when
they get infected but if the rate of
infection is down and they don't readily
transmit to their parents and family
members that's gonna be very important
in the decision making process of
opening schools hopefully we're gonna
find that out reasonably soon by this
study that we're doing an echo at dr.
Fauci said CDC has a number of what we
call household studies going on to try
to get a better understanding of how
does the virus get into a household who
brings it in what happens when it's in
the household
how does transmission vary depending on
how the household responds in terms of
social distancing etc so there is
information that we are gathering I
think we don't know the impact that
children have yet on the transmission
cycle so I think we should just
acknowledge that the greater threat
obviously is again those children to the
mul nerble but I think one can actually
have social behavior that can prevent
that so I think that would be just to
emphasize I think it's a really
important it's been said already that we
we move forward and and work to
reopening schools in a safe way I think
as of note that CDC never really
recommended closing schools it sort of
just happened as you know we can do
targeted school closings if we have to
in a particular region like we've done
for other viral diseases but I think we
really need to move forward now and and
work to how to reopen the school safely
Thank You Admiral girar just I want to
make sure you're we're tuned in and we
talked about a little bit are we going
to be able to make sure that we get
vaccines distributed in the most
vulnerable of communities because that
seems to be where so much is happening
right now in the rural South and are you
making specific plans to make sure that
we get that into the rural areas so
thank you very much so we all work on
parts of this problem right so the CDC
actually controls the distribution but
what my office
running the National Vaccine program
does things like the Morehouse grant
that were a cooperative agreement that
we that we announced last week that
really reaches into the rural into
Hispanic into african-american to really
have the community the people who are in
that community not only link to services
like like testing but to lay the
groundwork for vaccine acceptance
because we know that the burden of
disease is fundamentally burdened by on
these individuals so these are the
people assuming the science works out
that we want to get vaccinated first
alright great thank you thank you mr.
chairman Thank You senator Jones we know
the witnesses need to leave about one
we're going to try to respect that
Senator Rosen can you hear me yes we can
morning I will try to be as quick as I
can
talking about antibodies this morning
thank you chairman Alexander making
member Murray all of our witnesses for
being here today as our communities
focus on how safely get back to work in
school just like we're all talking about
we know we have to follow the science
and adapt to new information be sure
that we're making timely targeted and
thoughtful decisions protect both lives
and livelihoods
so dr. Fauci the last time you were here
we talked about the monoclonal antibody
treatments and I'd like to follow up on
that conversation if we could as if we
as we've learned more about the virus
how it functions how it's different from
other respiratory illnesses
what updates can you tell us about the
development of preventive treatments
that block the virus from attaching to
the cells that it's targeting well thank
you for the question senator you
mentioned monoclonal antibodies
monoclonal antibodies are going into
trials right now and a number of trials
sponsored by a number of groups
hopefully within a reasonable period of
time we'll get information as to whether
or not that's effective both in the
prevention as
well as in the treatment those
antibodies are directed against a
component of the virus that is what's
called the spike protein and that
protein is the one that binds to the now
well-established receptor in your body
for the virus and that's a receptacle a
stew
there are a number of other studies that
are not necessarily antibody studies but
studies that have a effect on the virus
itself and its initial replication in
answer to a question that the Chairman
mentions just a bit ago is that there
will be therapies that we will be giving
some for treatment early on and others
for prophylaxis and as we hope as we get
into the fall and winter we'll have
everything from small molecule
treatments and prophylaxis to the kinds
of antibodies that you're talking about
so there's a lot of activity going on to
do that early in disease both for
prevention and for the treatment of
early disease I know that you've been
doing a lot of serology testing and then
individuals are presenting with
antibodies so out of the five types of
antibodies that people are most likely
to have which ones do most recovers
patients which ones are they show and if
one of these specific antibodies are
present does that make a difference and
if the patient can be reinfected or not
or not are the effectively immune at
least for some period of time what kind
of answer is just just give us if you do
have the presence of certain antibiotics
so I'm I'd like I'd love to give you a
really precise scientifically based
answer but the fact is we don't know
standard wise when you get an acute
infection you get an IgM antibody as you
go off in time and develop a more chuma
Chur immune response it becomes an IgG
there are some cool subclasses of IgG
some more protective than others the
thing we don't know senator that we will
oh we will know in time but it's going
to take time to know it is what the
relationship between the neutral
anybody and binding antibodies that
don't neutralize what is the
relationship between the tighter and the
degree of protection and what is the
durability of protection we've seen some
puzzling things we've seen people
recover from kovat infection and find
out they don't have very high numbers of
anybody could it be a cell mediated
response that got them through the
illness and some other individuals have
very high levels and we don't know how
long those levels last so we're getting
there with regards to our knowledge but
it is going to take several more months
to a year to really be able to
definitively answer your question about
the role of antibodies in protection
following natural infection I'd like to
ask this question then we know that this
virus is multi-organ it can affect your
kidneys your lungs your heart producing
strokes all kinds of things your
digestive system your sense of smell so
I'm the science that you're talking
about the antibodies is the science of
stopping the virus from causing harm the
same regardless of which organ it
attacks and and how do we help direct
funding or the kind of research that
you're going to need to look at this
multi organ attack this virus if you
will this is a very perplexing virus
because it's a respiratory virus and it
gets in through the respiratory tract if
the virus stays in the respiratory tract
and doesn't go systemic to involve other
organs that's good news because you
don't get very sick the other side of
the coin is your antibody response is
not as potent because when you get
systemic involvement invariably you will
have a more potent and robust immune
response so many people and probably the
people who are the asymptomatic carriers
they have a reasonable titer of virus in
their nasal pharynx but the virus
doesn't go any other place in their body
people who get multi-system disease that
get triggered by the virus those are the
ones that unfortunately get more sick
but also the ones that make a more
potent immune response
thank you so much I appreciate you all
being here today Thank You senator Rosen
very interesting question senator Murray
do you have closing remarks uh Admiral
Gerrard one question yes ma'am thank you
despite some of the limited data we do
know that Koba 19 is infecting and
killing black Latino and Native American
people at a much higher rate than white
people I want to ask you how HHS is
going to adjust its response to reduce
cases and deaths and communities of
color and specifically can you commit to
redirect some of the 14 billion dollars
that is in unspent funds Congress
provided to address those disparities
let me answer the two parts of the
question first as you know and really
appreciate your support
we've tried to focus our testing into
high social vulnerability communities so
70% of our over 600 pharmacy sites are
in high svi communities that means
racial and ethnic minorities language to
disparities socioeconomic FQHCs we've
made a major push that the federally
qualified health centers that take care
of one out of three of those in poverty
over 1300 of those are now offering
testing and of course we're super
excited about the award to Morehouse
School of Medicine last week that has a
large coalition to create a national
infrastructure to reach to reach
minorities and underserved so that's
what we're really doing and you know my
office this is what we do on a on a
daily basis even without a pandemic your
second question is I don't commit the
money so I certainly think we need
continued investment in this area
continued significant investment in this
area that the 40 million dollars is the
down payment on how we could best reach
the underserved community but you're
going to have to talk to OMB about how
the money is spent question I'll keep
following up and tracking that yes
Thank You mr. chairman I appreciate all
of our witnesses taking the time to join
us today to update our Committee on the
course of this pandemic and all of our
efforts to respond to it I hopefully
will have continued to have an
opportunity to hear from all of you as
well as other key administration
officials about this because the
absolute worst thing we could do right
now is to pretend this crisis is over
when it is painfully obvious that is not
true the reality is that the losses in
this pandemic so far are merely
unthinkable and any further delays in
our response is really unacceptable we
need to take this president to take this
crisis seriously and lead and we need
Congress to act so I hope we can all get
back to work as soon as possible we need
to support our families or frontline
workers our businesses our schools our
communities we need to get testing where
it needs to be we need to make sure we
are making progress towards a safe
effective widely available vaccine and
we need to strengthen our ties with the
global community rather than cut them so
there's a lot left to do mr. chairman I
look forward to working with you on this
Thank You senator Murray I know our
witnesses have a meeting they need to go
to so I'll abbreviate my remarks but one
thing I want to ask you and perhaps you
can each do it in a minute or less I've
put out a white paper in recognition of
what some of you have said which is in
between pandemics we have found it
difficult to do some of the things we
need to do to prepare for the next
pandemic so there were one or two things
that you thought we should try to do now
in order to be prepared for the next
pandemic what would those one or two
things be dr. Falchi one of the things
that I would like to see is an
appreciation on the part of our entire
nation of the importance of responding
as a nation as a whole and not have a
situation where when you have a
challenge such as we have right now we
have very disparate responses we've
to do it in a coordinated way because we
are all in this together
the other thing I'd like to do now is to
cement in our minds as we bridge to the
future the fact that we cannot forget
that what was thought to be unimaginable
turned out to be the reality that we're
facing right now so it relates to the
kind of appreciation that outbreaks
happen and you have to deal with them
and in a very aggressive proactive way
dr. Redfield Thank You mr. chairman I
think the most important thing that I
could say is that when it comes to
public health threats our nation needs
to be over-prepared not underprepared
and as I mentioned before decades of
underinvestment investing investment in
the core capabilities of public health
data modernization laboratory resilience
workforce mergers a response I think is
fundamental we've really been hit with
this simple virus and I think at the end
of the day it's gonna cost our nation
trillions of dollars and I think that we
have a moment in time where I think
people are attuned and I would say now's
the time to make the necessary
investment in our public health at the
local territorial tribal state in
federal level so that this nation
finally has the public health system not
only that it needs but that it deserves
hey Roger ah of course I agree
completely with my colleagues and we're
all singing from the same hymnal here
I'll say three things number one data
infrastructure is really important when
we came into this we didn't know how
many ventilators were in use how many
tests were out there where the tests
positive or negative who is being tested
I mean the complete soup-to-nuts
infrastructure that we need to make
decisions you need those data to make
decisions and to allocate resources
and now that we built this on the fly
but we absolutely have to invest in that
secondly I would say resiliency of the
healthcare system yes we need to attack
kovat but what happens to everything
else we've seen cancer screenings go
down by 80% childhood immunizations
plummet just about every other thing in
the healthcare system
was sacrificed for our covert response
so it's not just the pandemic response
but it's everything else we need to do
and the third thing I would say is we
continue have to focus on health
disparities um if everyone was healthier
in this country if we invested into
those two hypertension diabetes obesity
all the things that could bring the
general health up you would not see as
horrible of outcomes as we have in any
pandemic so working on health
disparities that have been here for
decades is I think critical to raise our
in general health and prepare us for
whatever is going to hit us dr. Han you
can have the last word Thank You mr.
chairman
first of all thank you for your
leadership on your white paper or I
think that's really important to put
this conversation forward there are two
things I want to emphasize one is the
data modernization but from an FDA
perspective it's a very manual process
to number one collect data on demand and
also so the supply chain we need a very
robust system to understand that we also
need a robust real-world evidence
approach so that when we make decisions
in real time during an emergency doctors
do that all the time agencies do that
particularly during public health
emergencies we have the appropriate data
infrastructure to collect real-world
evidence and feedback into our decisions
and then revise those decisions as
needed critically important for the
agency and the second thing is linked
and that is to my previous comments that
Senator Lafleur asked about we
absolutely need redundancy in the supply
chain when you redundancy manufacturing
and we need to emphasize the importance
of domestic manufacturing thank you
thank you dr. Hahn well the one thing
this sneaky dangerous virus has reminded
us is that there will be another sneaky
dangerous virus one day and and we know
from experience that it may be easier to
take the steps you've just described
while our eyes
the ball rather than between pandemics
because we get interested in other
issues I'm grateful to the witnesses for
your time I think the senators on both
sides of the aisle for really careful
insightful and courteous questioning the
hearing record will remain open for 10
days members may submit additional
information within that time if they
would like thank you for being here the
committee will stand adjourned